[Music]
this footage shows the miami inside the
bayavista prison in santo domingo dozens
of dead bodies are seen piled on the
bloodied floor
the inmates were killed in an overnight
fight between rival gangs officials say
it was triggered by the arrival of a
gang leader it is the latest in a series
of deadly riots inside ecuador's prisons
most of the victims if not almost 100
were killed with a knife and not with a
firearm and most of the bodies were
exposed and assaulted in the wards and
in the cells
distraught relatives rushed to the
prison desperate to find out what have
happened
while many were killed some managed to
escape
more than a hundred were recaptured on
monday
we found out about the riot when my
relative called to say they were
exploding dynamite with firearms inside
they were entering the cells to kill
everyone
we don't know if he's dead or alive yet
we want to know if he's dead or alive
that's what we want
nearly 400 inmates have been killed in
prison riots in little over a year
ecuador has seen an increase in gang
violence as rival groups supported by
mexican drug cartels battle for control
of transit routes for cocaine smuggled
from peru in colombia
last month president guillermo lasso
declared a 60-day state of emergency in
three western provinces increasing the
police and military presence but it has
so far failed to stop the bloodshed
some observers say the problem is
systemic the reason why
violence keeps increasing in equilibrium
prisons is because they have there's a
neural center
of the drug cartels in ecuador so every
time there is a gang dispute in ecuador
it always manifests in in
extreme
bloody
gang violence within the prison walls a
level of brutality never seen before in
this country and that the government
seems unable to bring under control
alessandra
al jazeera